le sénat devrait examiner à partir du
mois de juin en commission un texte très
différent de celui déposé initialement
par le gouvernement puisqu'il a triplé
de volume passant de 69 articles à 218
toutefois les thèmes toutefois les
thèmes la technicité la porte et la
normativité et les impacts sont très
différents d'une mesure à l'autre quand
une étude précise des impacts et
disponible dès lors la préhension de la
cohérence globale du texte est la mesure
de l'impact et de ses dispositions sur
nos émissions et notre empreinte carbone
sont devenues difficiles à appréhender
alors même que le haut conseil pour le
climat
mesure
les provocations et modifications de
mesure à peine ou non entre en vigueur
dès coordination de mesures anticipées
avec d'autres textes qui pourrait être
examinée au parlement dans les prochains
mois ou années et quelques mesures
d'interdiction et d'effets directs mais
aussi désormais une quarantaine de
demandes de rapports du gouvernement au
parlement
il ya également une demi-douzaine
d'habilitation à légiférer par
ordonnances sur des sujets très variés
essentielles ou et plus ou moins
sensible mais qui auraient tous mérités
des discussions plus approfondies au
parlement je pense notamment à la
réforme du code minier ou à la réforme
de la gestion du recul de trait de côte
par exemple qui n'étaient pas dans le
champ de la réflexion de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat par le
président de la république
sauf erreur de ma part les dispositions
prévues initialement pour être prise par
voie d'ordonnancé ont été inscrits dans
le corps du texte
c'est une bonne chose mais il reste deux
vastes champs d'habilitation par
ailleurs vous savez ce texte ne permet
toujours pas d'atteindre nos objectifs
de réduction des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici à 2030 temps par
rapport à la cible actuelle de -40% que
par rapport à la nouvelle cible de -55%
que l'union européenne se donne avec le
soutien de la france
donc ce qui devait être un texte de
bilan pour accéder à certaines mesures
déjà prises depuis le début du
quinquennat et ouvrir de nouveaux champs
d'action apparaît finalement en retrait
par rapport à l'objectif initial
on a aussi le sentiment que certains
sujets n'étaient pas tout à fait prêt
car plusieurs missions ont travaillé sur
des dispositions du texte à la demande
du gouvernement alors même que l'examen
parlementaire avait déjà commencé à
l'assemblée
je pense aux mesures relatives à la
régulation de la publicité avec les
missions confiées
arnaud leroy et agathe bousquet ou à la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
avec la mission confiée à olivier sichel
par exemple enfin pour faciliter
enfin pour vous faciliter la tâche
si j'ose dire ce texte suscite de vives
réactions de la société opinion d'un
côté certains accusent d'aller trop loin
et d'ignorer le contexte sanitaire et
économique actuelle d'un autre côté
certains soulignent toujours son manque
d'ambition des
déséquilibres et des renoncements aux
trop nombreux du gouvernement donc
problème les mini je compte sur vous
pour nous éclairer sur ce nouveau texte
issu des travaux des députés que nous
aurons a examiné dans les prochaines
semaines et j'en viens aux deux
questions que je souhaitais vous poser
avant de vous laisser la parole
d'abord quelles sont pour vous et le
gouvernement auquel vous appartenez les
mesures les plus importantes du texte et
celles auxquelles vous tenait
particulièrement parmi les deux cent dix
huit articles du texte
ma deuxième question le gouvernement
envisage-t-il de compléter le texte
en proposant d'insérer en dur des
dispositions qui sont actuellement dans
des habilitations à légiférer par
ordonnance
quels éléments le gouvernement souhaite
il voir évoluer par rapport au texte
adopté par les députés
voilà madame la mini jeux vous cède la
parole et je vous remercie encore une
fois pour votre présence et votre
disponibilité
6 merci beaucoup monsieur le président
je suis ravi d'être à vos côtés
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs bonjour bonjour à toutes et à
tous je suis venu aujourd'hui vous
proposer d'écrire ensemble une nouvelle
page de notre histoire
une page qui sera faite de démocratie et
d'écologie et une page qui a été écrite
et c'est nouveau
avec toutes les forces vives de notre
pays grâce au travail des femmes et des
hommes qui n'ont d'autres titres que de
celui de citoyen et une page qui a été
complétée renforcer comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le président densifier par
le travail exigeant des députés et je
crois que au milieu d'une crise
sanitaire qui semblent n'en pas finir
c'est bien ce dont nous avons toutes et
tous besoin oui il ya urgence
il ya urgence à construire un autre
avenir pour nos territoires à les
protéger des conséquences du dérèglement
climatique
urgence à réinventer une civilisation
qui provoque aujourd'hui canicule cru
mortels cyclones et tempêtes par son
inconséquence urgence à conduire
l'humanité à l'âge adulte avec une
pleine conscience du danger que nos
comportements font courir et de la
fragilité de notre planète
c'est l'appel des 150 l'appel de notre
jeunesse et la tête du pays tout entier
alors nous devons agir vite
nous devons agir bien nous devons faire
différemment et faire mieux et je crois
que ce grand défi de notre temps et
l'occasion de retisser aussi des liens
dont notre pays a besoin de rassembler
d'unir d' arrêter d'opposer et de
retrouver ce goût d'un avenir partagé à
construire ensemble pour chacune et
chacun des enfants de la république où
qu'ils vivent et d'où qu'ils viennent
c'est cela à mon sens faire nation dans
notre nouveau siècle et c'est bien à cet
exercice que se sont attelés les 150
membres de la convention citoyenne qui
ont été tirés au sort
pendant neuf mois ils ont donné de leur
temps ils ont donné de leur énergie pour
apporter leur concours à notre vie
collective
au départ il n'était ni expert ni des
convaincu de la cause environnementale
ils viennent de tous les coins de france
il représente tous les métiers toutes
les catégories sociales
ils ont discuté ils ont débattu ils ont
proposé et ils ont fait vivre finalement
c'est beau mot de citoyens et de
démocratie dans ce qu'il ya de plus
noble et depuis sincère et je veux
redire ici ma fierté devant leur
héritage démocratique et écologique
maintenant le temps du parlement est
venu et maintenant c'est à vous
sénatrices et sénateurs de concrétiser
ce travail entamé et de transformer
l'essai alors bien sûr monsieur
président l'a souligné beaucoup
critiqueront le rythme de transformation
trop rapide ou trop lent
c'est selon mais j'ai cette conviction
acquise de longue date
s'il faut assumer des ruptures dans
certaines politiques publiques
on ne transforme pas un pays dans la
brutalité il faut donner l'impulsion
il faut doser entre la contrainte et
l'initiative est accompagné chacune et
chacun
il faut désigner destinée cette écologie
pratique de terrain réaliste et concrète
une écologie qui serait pragmatique et
qui remet comme tout simplement du bon
sens dans nos vies et tout commence à
l'école de la république c'est pour cela
que cette loi fera entrer l'écologie
dans les salles de classe pour former
des futurs citoyens aux enjeux du siècle
cette loi va aussi nous donner des
moyens pour faire de chaque citoyen un
acteur d'une consommation plus
responsable en indiquant sur des
produits et services leur bilan
environnemental
en transformant les représentations qui
sont véhiculées par la publicité et en
définissant le greenwashing ou
écoblanchiment ans pour ce qu'il est
c'est-à-dire une pratique commerciale
trompeuse
c'est l'ambition du titre 1 avec cette
voie nous allons aussi porté la
transition écologique au coeur des
entreprises avec les instances de
représentation des salariés
nous allons mobiliser la commande
publique pour accélérer la des communes
carbo nation notre économie les clauses
environnementales seront obligatoires
dans les marchés publics
nous allons aussi mieux ancrer les
énergies renouvelables dans les
territoires pour renforcer
l'acceptabilité des projets c'est tout
le sens du titre 2 mais d'amener
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs cette
loi va aussi nous permettre de protéger
directement des milliers de nos
concitoyens exposé chroniquement à un
air irrespirable
on en connaît le coût humain les
maladies respiratoires
quarante mille morts chaque année alors
oui nous allons créer des zones à
faibles émissions dans toutes les
grandes villes de france pour mettre un
terme à la circulation des véhicules les
plus polluants sous les fenêtres de nos
enfants
oui cette loi enrichi de sa première
lecture à l'assemblée va permettre à nos
concitoyens de bénéficier de la prime à
la conversion pour se tourner vers des
vélos à assistance électrique remettre
du bon sens dans notre vie collective
c'est aussi reconnaître l'absurdité qui
consiste à prendre l'avion alors qu'on
peut faire le même trajet avec un train
direct en moins de 2h30 ce sont les
objectifs du titre iii remettre du bon
sens dans notre vie c'est aussi
l'ambition du titre iv d'abord pour
arrêter d'engloutir la nature sous le
béton pour arrêter de construire des
centres commerciaux dans les champs pour
diviser par deux le rythme
d'artificialisation des sols mais ce bon
sens dont je vous parle c'est aussi
d'agir pour mettre fin à la situation
intenable de 2 millions de près de deux
millions de foyers français vivant en
location dans des passoires thermiques
l'été ils suffoquent l'hiver il grelotte
et entre les deux il paye des factures
exorbitantes et nous pouvons éviter cela
en évitant du même coup des millions de
tonnes de co2 rejetées dans l'atmosphère
alors avec cette fois nous interdisons
la mise en location de ces passoire pour
conduire les propriétaires à réel
des rénovations de qualité et nous avons
une trajectoire claire pour y arriver
d'abord les classes j'ai les plus
consommatrices d'énergie ce sont près de
600 mille logements qui sont concernés
et leur location en l'état sera
interdite d'ici quatre ans en 2025
ensuite pour la classe f qui représente
1,2 million de locations l'interdiction
interviendra en 2028
enfin pour la classe e et ses plus de 2
millions de locations qui devront être
rénovés avant 2034
ce calendrier laisse à chacune et à
chacun le temps pour s'adapter
il évite aussi la saturation des
professionnels parce que j'entends bien
que certains voudraient tout interdire
demain matin mais encore faut-il que la
filière se soient structurées et que les
propriétaires et la capacité de réaliser
ces travaux qu'ils soient accompagnés et
cet accompagnement
il est aussi garantie dans la durée par
cette loi avec la création des
accompagnateurs rénovation agréé par
l'état
ils auront l'importante mission de
soutenir des ménages de a à z de la
conception de leur projet à sa
réalisation en passant par le montage
financier et le choix des artisans
enfin ce sera simple enfin on sortira
des procédures extrêmement complexe à
laquelle il faut avoir passé des études
entière et des dizaines d'années pour
comprendre comment on pouvait obtenir
les aides
nous avons conscience de l'effort que
nous demandons à ces millions de
propriétaires et c'est bien pourquoi la
loi doit fixer un principe d'engagement
financier de l'état pour accompagner les
ménages en garantissant un reste à
charge faible notamment pour les plus
précaires ce principe que les députés
ont tenu à ajouter au texte pour qu'il
soit gravé dans le marbre de la loi se
traduira chaque année dans les lois de
finances
et oui c'est bien en confiance que nous
y arriverons car cette transformation de
notre habitat c'est aussi une question
de cohérence et de prévisibilité
mesdames et messieurs et sénatrices et
sénateurs cette loi c'est aussi
l'occasion de donner une nouvelle
impulsion à la transformation de notre
modèle agricole et alimentaire en
développant une agro écologie au service
des territoires des humains et de la
nature en luttant contre la
déforestation apportées en donnant à
chacune à chacun le droit à une
alimentation plus saine plus équilibrée
en ouvrant davantage le choix un menu
végétarien
et en mettant en parallèle dans la
commande des commandes de viande qu'ils
soient de bonne qualité qu'ils soient
labellisés
c'est le programme du titre 5 vous voyez
cette loi acte un changement d'ère le
début d'une nouvelle époque une époque
où la destruction volontaire de la
nature les dépôts sauvages les
pollutions qui pourraient être évités
sont intolérables et je le dis et je le
redis la complaisance avec les pollueurs
s'est terminé alors oui nous renforçons
notre droit notre cadre juridique avec
le titre 6 nous nous donnons enfin les
moyens d'agir avec diligence et sévérité
contre ceux qui portent gravement
atteinte à l'environnement et c'est un
grand pas en avant
et lorsque je le dise comme je le disais
il ya un instant je suis attaché
profondément à ce temps que nous prenons
ensemble vous et moi aux débats
parlementaires au travail des élus de la
nation c'est que je sais combien ce
travail améliore les lois je vous ai
déjà mentionné les avancées notables
certaines qui ont été issus de plus de
200 heures de débat à l'assemblée
je n'ai pas encore parlé du nouveau
titre de septième qui est venu enrichir
ce texte et sa portée dans le temps long
car pour relever cet immense défi qu'on
appelle la transition nous avons besoin
d'un cadre robuste pour nous assurer que
notre exigence ne faiblit pas et les
évolutions de notre gouvernance
climatique adopté par les députés vont
dans le bon sens pour cela l'évaluation
de la mise en oeuvre de cette loi chaque
année par le haut conseil pour le climat
et la cour des comptes
c'est une excellente manière d'agir en
cohérence et en responsabilité et c'est
le même esprit qui doit animer la
négociation de feuille de route
secteur par secteur mettre autour de la
table les acteurs qui vont concrètement
agir faire bouger leurs modèles pour
atteindre nos objectifs climatiques
commun c'est le prérequis le gage d'une
coordination efficace de chacune des
actions de chacun des engagements pour
atteindre nos objectifs
alors bien sûr une seule loi ne peut
transformer un pays aussi ambitieuse
soit elle et quand j'entends certains
dire que cette loi n'est pas suffisante
pour aboutir aux objectifs de 40% de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre en
je confirme bien sûr ce projet devant
nous c'est une nouvelle pierre à un
édifice beaucoup plus large que nous
bâtissons depuis le premier jour elle
vient avec des décisions que personne
n'avait osé prend
avant comme l'abandonnent notre dame des
landes d'europa cité de la montagne d'or
du t4 de roissy elle vient avec un plan
de relance historique qui consacre 30
milliards d'euros à la décarbonation de
notre économie
elle vient avec de nombreuses mesures
réglementaires et d'accompagnement des
mesures aussi fiscale et elle vient avec
notre mobilisation internationale sans
faille pour forger des consensus qui
feront date pour faire de l'europe une
puissance poussant nos partenaires
commerciaux à s'aligner sur notre niveau
d'ambition alors mesdames et mais les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
maintenant ce texte il est à vous et je
sais qu'ensemble nous pouvons faire
vivre cette écologie de terrain et de
bon sens je sais que nous partageons la
même volonté de transformer notre
système notre pays le quotidien des
françaises et des français je vous
remercie votre invitation à venir devant
vous aujourd'hui je me tiens à votre
disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
questions et pour répondre tout d'abord
aux questions de monsieur le président
je voudrais vous répondre que si je ne
devais retenir que quelques mesures mais
c'est très dur de choix que vous me
demandez de faire dans ce texte très
très large
je dirais que parmi les mesures qui me
semble plus cher il y à quelques mesures
structurantes et quelques mesures qui
sont plus des mesures de changement de
modèle mesures structurantes
il y avait bien sûr des mesures sur la
rénovation des bâtiments
je rappelle que le bâtiment c'est 25% de
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
donc le fait de mettre en place des
mesures qui vont concrètement pouvoir
faire baisser ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et qui ont en plus un
impact social fort ça fait partie des
mesures qui sont très importantes
à mon sens deuxième mesure structurante
c'est la mise en place des zones à
faibles émissions
les zones à faibles émissions c'est un
effort sans précédent pour la santé
publique ça va concerner la moitié de la
population française mais c'est un c'est
un effort qu'on demande aux
collectivités sur le terrain j'étais à
marseille lundi
on a eu j'ai eu beaucoup de questions
sur la mise en place de l'aser des feux
parce que ça nécessite un accompagnement
social
ça nécessite un accompagnement aussi
pour nos artisans par exemple qui ont
besoin de pouvoir continuer à rentrer à
l'intérieur de ces vies pour travailler
et nous avons évidemment prévu des
mesures d'accompagnement parce que
toutes mesures mises en place dans cette
loi quand il ya des personnes
et catégorie de personnes qui sont visés
il y à des mesures d'accompagnement qui
sont mises en place soit dans la loi
soit par des mesures réglementaires et
fiscales à côté troisième mesure
importante
les mesures sur l'artificialisation des
sols
nous ne pouvons continuer à bétonner nos
sols avec un rythme aussi fort nous
avons un objectif à long terme qui est
zéro artificielle artificialisation net
et nous avons une mesure intermédiaire
qui va nous permettre de diviser par
deux d'ici dix ans notre rythme
d'artificialisation je le vois déjà sur
le terrain j'ai discuté avec des maires
qui me disaient mais que tout simplement
maintenant on change d'état d'esprit
c'est à dire que quand on a un projet
dont on commence à regarder
est-ce que j'ai pas un endroit une
friche par exemple où je pourrais mettre
ce projet plutôt que d'aller sur une
terre agricole
évidemment c'est encore une fois une
mesure accompagnée puisque le fond
friche des 300 millions d'euros que nous
mettons à disposition des collectivités
pour cela et puis des mesures plus
culturelle mais très importante à mon
sens ce sera les mesures menu végétarien
des mesures aussi sur le remplacement
des trajets en avion par le train quand
quand il ya des alternatives en train ou
encore le fameux carbone score qui est
déporté par les membres de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat et qui veut
dire tout simplement que il y aura un
étiquetage qui permettra aux
consommateurs de voir du premier coup
d'oeil si le produit qu'ils achètent est
bon ou mauvais pour l'environnement et
ce qui pourra les aider dans leur choix
enfin sur les ordonnances dont vous avez
parlé monsieur le président nous avons
déjà commencé à traduire un certain
nombre d' ordonnance dans le dur de la
loi pas dans l'examen devant les députés
au sénat moi je ne suis absolument pas
fermé à la possibilité qu'on puisse le
faire également sur d'autres ordonnances
qu'il faudra juste qu'on regarde et il
faudra vraiment qu'on regarde au cas par
cas
c'est des ordonnances qui sont purement
techniques qui sont par exemple du
nettoyage de code sur notamment
l'urbanisme qui ne nécessite pas détenir
dans le dur de la loi et qui alourdirait
considérablement la loi qui n'ont pas
trop d'intérêt et d'autres ordonnances
qui serait plus adapté pour pour cette
transcription donc il faudra vraiment
qu'on regarde mais
en tout cas je suis tout à fait ouverte
à l'idée et enfin par rapport à ce que
demande et la convention citoyenne vous
parlez de l'ajout du code minier ou du
trait de côte
alors pour le code minier il y avait des
mesures qui concernait justement des
grands projets comme la montagne d'or où
la lutte contre l'orpaillage illégal et
donc la réforme du code minier permet de
répondre à ces questions mais évidemment
nous avons profité il faut le dire de
cette loi pour mettre en place un
certain nombre de mesures qui était
attendue depuis longtemps qui avait fait
l'objet de travail de parlementaires que
ce soit sur le code minier ou sur le
trait de côte et dont on voyait que
l'encombrement du calendrier
parlementaire risquait de nous empêcher
de les mener à bien d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
or notamment par exemple sur la montagne
d'or
nous avons des des risques juridiques
des risques de contentieux pendant qu'il
faut absolument qu'on puisse contenir et
la réforme du code minier va nous le
permettre de la même manière sur le
trait de côte
nous avons des élus qui nous a l'air
très régulièrement nous avons eu un
problème du signal du fameux immeuble du
signal qui n'est que le premier cas de
nombreux cas qui vont se présenter et on
avait besoin de réformer notre
législation est donc c'est un acte
volontaire politique de mettre ça dans
la loi voilà j'ai déjà été trop donc
pardon monsieur le président je vous
remercie madame merci madame lamy
chappuis est bien fait de devenir ce que
j'ai pas moins de vingt demandes de
parole donc c'est que effectivement nous
collections par plus clairement et rsr
je vais proposer de donner la parole aux
trois rapporteurs que sont martin de
sidrac pascal martin et philippe tabarot
et également donné la parole à ronan
dantec qui est président du groupe de
travail climat et après vous pourrez
répondre et après je re 21 avec
guillaume cette fois ci et qui est
et qui est le président du groupe de
travail et après vous répondrai à ces
quatre questions et je redonnerai la
parole aux trois rapporteur pour avis
voilà madame martin de sida je vous
n'avez parle merci président madame la
ministre je concentrerai mes questions
sur le titre 1 et le titre 6 du projet
de loi
je m'étonne que plusieurs articles du
projet de loi reviennent sur des
équilibres atteints lors de récents
débats parlementaires ce qui soulève
évidemment d'importantes questions quant
à la lisibilité de la norme est de la
qualité de la loi
je pense notamment à deux articles du
projet de loi les articles 9 et 12 qui
rejoue en quelque sorte la loi geiq
promulguée il ya un peu plus d'un an
concernant le premier article le neuf je
m'interroge sur la capacité de
l'expérimentation prévue à distinguer
les résultats propres
oh oui pub de ceux de la loi geiq qui a
introduit un régime de sanctions
stop-pub ce chevauchement des
initiatives at il été prise en compte
lors de la rédaction du projet de loi
concernant l'article 12 je vous rappelle
qu'à l'occasion de la loi geiq le sénat
avait permis au pouvoir réglementaire de
faire obligation aux producteurs ou à
l'éco organisme dont ils relèvent de
mettre en oeuvre des dispositifs de
consignes autre que la consigne pour
recyclage sur les bouteilles plastiques
la version de l'article 12 qui nous a
été transmise par l'assemblée nationale
ne fait que décliner cette possibilité à
la consigne pour ré emploi sur les
emballages en verre
cet article est il utile juridiquement
ou ne constitue-t-il un support de
communication de votre part madame la
ministre
par ailleurs l'article 1er qui porte sur
l'affichage environnemental revient lui
aussi sur une disposition introduite par
la loi gec et dont l'évaluation est
attendu pour le mois d'août 2021 alors
que plusieurs secteurs textile
ameublement aménagements touristiques
alimentaires sont engagés dans ces
démarches qui depuis les lois grenelle 1
et 2 ce qui montre au passage que cette
île et d'affichage environnemental n'est
pas neuve je m'interroge sur l'entrée en
vigueur tardive du dispositif
après cinq ans d'expérimentation tel que
cela est prévu par le projet de loi ne
pensez vous pas qu'il serait important
de mettre en oeuvre ce dispositif plus
rapidement tant au service de la
formation des consommateurs que de la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
l'affichage environnemental nous semble
en effet être un élément puissant pour
accompagner la décarbonation de notre
modèle économique et créer des avantages
comparatifs pour les entreprises
françaises
par ailleurs une précision a été
introduite à l'assemblée nationale pour
tenir compte de la situation des
entreprises de moins de 21 salariés
à quoi correspond ce seuil à l'article
11 je partage la volonté de développer
davantage le vrac qui répond à une
aspiration de beaucoup de français à la
réduction des déchets d'emballages se
fixer des objectifs comme le fait
l'article 11 peut à cet égard avoir un
intérêt il me semble cependant que poser
une obligation de résultat ne suffit pas
il y à de nombreuses barrières
techniques et pratiques à lever pour
pérenniser le vrac
comment l'état peut-il mieux accompagner
les acteurs notamment par le biais
d'expérimentation par exemple pour
limiter les risques de gaspillage
alimentaire induit pour adapter la
réglementation relatives à l'étiquetage
des produits alimentaires ou encore pour
lever les contraintes techniques
empêchant aujourd'hui la vente en vrac
de certains produits de consommation à
l'article 11 contre l'avis du
gouvernement plusieurs amendements ont
été adoptés en séance publique afin
d'interdire à partir de 2025 les
emballages constitué en polystyrène
il n'existe certes pas aujourd'hui en
france de filières opérationnel de
recyclage du polystyrène
mais plusieurs projets de recyclage
chimiques ont été récemment annoncées en
france
au son au stade du pilote technologique
ne serait-il pas contradictoire
d'interdire ces emballages alors même
que nous consacrons des millions d'euros
à la recherche de solutions de recyclage
dans la perspective notamment de
l'objectif de 100 % d'emballages
recyclables
d'ici 2025 posées par la loi à gec
pouvez vous nous en dire plus sur
l'avancée de ces projets j'aimerais
également revenir sur l'article 6 qui
prévoit une décentralisation du pouvoir
de police de la publicité aux communes
et aux intercommunalités ne disposant
pas d'un rpg des difficultés à
comprendre l'objectif visé par cet
article ne risque-t-il pas de mettre en
difficulté les petites collectivités qui
ne disposent pas de la capacité à
contrôler et sanctionner les éventuels
atteinte au code de la
ironnement enfin s'agissant du titre 6
du projet de loi consacré à la
protection judiciaire de l'environnement
vous parait-il souhaitable que le
nouveau délit de mise en danger de
l'environnement soient punis plus
sévèrement que le délit de mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui prévue par le
code pénal
trois ans d'emprisonnement contre un an
d'emprisonnement
comment les juges seront amenés à
apprécier la qualification juridique de
la teinte durable susceptible de durer
au moins 10 ans en termes de lisibilité
de proportionnalité de l'échelle des
peines vous paraît-il opportun de
sanctionner plus sévèrement une mise en
danger de l'environnement qui n'a pas
causé de dommages que certaine
dégradation substantielle de
l'environnement vise évidemment à
l'article l 173 3 du code de
l'environnement
je vous remercie madame la ministre
merci le rapporteur merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
chers collègues mes questions porteront
sur plusieurs titres du projet de loi
concernant le verdissement de la
commande publique
je salue les avancées du texte à l'issue
des débats à l'assemblée nationale
en effet l'extension de l'article 15 au
contrat de concession semble tout
particulièrement opportune nous savons
cependant que le recours à la norme ne
suffira pas et qu'un véritable
verdissement de la commande publique
devra également passer par la formation
et l'accompagnement des acheteurs
publics d outils d analyse de cycle de
vie
pourrait-il par exemple être mise à
disposition des collectivités
territoriales par l'état
s'agissant du volet relatif à l'eau qui
ne comportait initialement qu'un article
le 19 relatifs aux écosystèmes
aquatiques
alors que le texte qui nous est transmis
en comporte désormais 6 je souhaiterais
vous qu'est l'eau très controversé
article 19 bis c'est sur la continuité
écologique et l'interdiction des
destructions de moulins à eau qui a fait
l'objet d'âpres discussions
ne pourrait-on pas retenir une recette
une rédaction plus équilibrée qui
permettrait la circulation des espèces
aquatiques ainsi que le transport des
sédiments
tout en rassurant les propriétaires de
moulins à eau
inquiet de ce qu'ils décrivent comme je
cite une politique de
destruction des ouvrages dans le cadre
d'une continuité écologique apaisé ce
texte comprend en outre un article 19
bis g prévoyant un programme d'action
chiffré visant à améliorer le
fonctionnement des ouvrages équipements
de distribution d'eau potable
ne serait-il pas au portant opportun
pardon de prévoir un plan national de
lutte contre les pertes du réseau de
distribution d'eau potable et
d'amélioration de sa performance
lorsqu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui le taux de
suite moyen en france est de 20%
j'aimerais également vous interrogé sur
l'inscription dans la loi mais c'est
l'article 56 de la stratégie nationale
pour les aires protégées avec un double
objectif de 30% des terrestres et
marines sous protection et 10% sous
protection forte
l'ambition est louable notamment pour
les airs sous protection forte car nous
ne sommes pas loin de l'atteinte des
objectifs de 30 % de zone protégée alors
que nous en sommes plus éloignés pour
les 10% sous protection forte
se pose donc à mes yeux la question des
moyens humains et des financements pour
y parvenir
s'ils sont insuffisants ses moyens ces
zones ne seront que désert de papier en
raison de l'article 40 de la
constitution
nous pouvons cependant pas leur
consacrer de nouveaux moyens ensuite le
principe de non régression des surfaces
ne concerne que la superficie totale ce
qui signifie que les airs sous
protection forte pourrait voir leur
superficie réduite entre deux
actualisation ce qui interroge sur les
ambitions portées par la france enfin
nous pensons que renvoyer la définition
de la protection forte à un décret n'est
pas satisfaisant à la lumière de ces
interrogations
pourriez vous nous préciser vos
engagements concernant l'atteinte des
objectifs de la stratégie nationale pour
les aires protégées
enfin j'aurai deux dernières questions
plus direct si vous me permettez
l'expression
d'abord ne pensez vous pas que
l'introduction de la réforme du code
minier
il fait référence aux articles 20 et 21
dans ce texte déséquilibre son bilan
carbone global
si l'on peut attendre une amélioration
de notre
empreinte carbone avec une exploitations
minières nationales dans une logique de
relocalisation industrielle
on peut en revanche s'attendre à une
hausse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre induites par l'exploitation
minière et la transformation des
produits issus de l'extraction
enfin s'agissant de l'article 60 2 sur
les engrais pourriez vous madame la
ministre nous éclairer sur sa portée
juridique car elle ne m'apparaît pas
clair soit le dispositif prévoyant une
redevance sur les engrais azotés fait
obligation au gouvernement de mettre en
oeuvre cette taxe non défini d'ailleurs
auquel cas il s'agit d'une injonction
gouvernement ce qui est contraire à la
constitution soit cet article n'a aucun
effet juridique mais uniquement une
vocation politique auquel cas je
souhaiterais que vous me précisiez son
intérêt je vous remercie
merci monsieur reporter je vais donner
la parole à philippe tabarot merci
président madame la ministre et chers
collègues je souhaiterais quand avant
vous interroger sur le titre iii se
déplacer l'article 27 du projet de loi
relatif aux zones à faibles émissions
mobilité modifie considérablement le
cadre juridique qui est prévu par la loi
d'orientation des mobilités rapportés
ici même il ya quelques temps par
l'excellent sénateurs mandelli alors que
les aides à feu était prévu comme un
outil à la main des collectivités
territoriales afin de s'adapter à leurs
besoins
l'article 27 impose des interdictions de
circulation à échéances courtes
2023/2024 2025 qui concerne 2 millions
de véhicules selon l'étude d'impact
pourquoi avoir fait ce choix de mettre
un seuil minimal de restrictions l'étude
d'impact indique également que ces
véhicules auraient été remplacés
naturellement d'ici 2028 la mise en
oeuvre de zdf at elle une véritable
valeur ajoutée pour accélérer de trois
ans ce renouvellement
par ailleurs et toujours sur l'article
27 l'étude d'impact comporte peu
d'éléments sur les impacts économiques
de cette mesure sur les particuliers
les entreprises en particulier à la
suite de l'adoption à l'assemblée
nationale d'un amendement visant à
éteindre à étendre pardon les mesures de
restriction des aides à feurs aux
véhicules utilitaires légers
avez vous chiffré quelles pourraient
être les faits de la mise en place d un
des feux sur l'activité des artisans des
travailleurs utilisant ces véhicules
concernant les particuliers ne peut-on
pas penser que les ménages qui seront
les plus impactés par la nécessité de
renouvellement de leur véhicule sont les
plus précaires
en fait vous en mesure de chiffrer le
coût des moyens de contrôle humain
automatisé qui seront nécessaires pour
de les déployer alors même que les
dispositifs de contrôle automatisé prévu
par là l'homme ne sont pas encore
opérationnels
en outre le projet de loi fixe des
objectifs ambitieux de décarbonation de
poids lourds d'ici 2040
cependant force est de constater que les
véhicules industriels électriques ou à
hydrogène ne sont pour l'heure ni
disponible ni abordable pour les
transporteurs routiers
ainsi des mesures comme la diminution de
l'avantagé fiscal sur la tei cpe revêt
un caractère punitif
sans pour autant sa compagne et d'être
suffisante de l'état en effet le bonus
écologique du gouvernement est temps
limité aux motorisations hydrogène
électrique et expirante 2022
il paraît pas adapté aux préoccupations
du secteur objectivement rassurer bercy
ils n'auront pas grand-chose à débourser
cette année concernant l'aide à
l'hydrogène qui n'existe pas au niveau
des camions comptez vous revoir le
périmètre ou en tout cas la durée de ces
aides à la transition
par ailleurs le projet de loi ne traite
pas de la question des biocarburants
alors qu'il s'agit probablement d'une
solution certes transitoire mais
extrêmement intéressante en matière de
décarbonation pourriez vous nous
préciser les raisons qui ont amené le
gouvernement avec sur les biocarburants
de levier décarbonation dont la france
pourrait se doter
avec ce projet de loi j'en viens présent
l'article 32 de ce projet
il prévoit d'autoriser le gouvernement à
légiférer par ordonnance pour un site
situé aussi que tout le monde connaît
bien une contribution régionale à six
sur la circulation des véhicules de
transport de marchandises
voilà on l'appelle comme on veut je sais
que la sémantique est importante pour ce
sujet je pense que vous avez tous
compris de quoi je parle
cette contribution qui serait fondée sur
le transfert de la compétence des routes
aux régions soulève plusieurs questions
pouvez vous nous en dire plus sur le
dispositif envisagé à ce stade tout
d'abord disposez-vous d'informations
relatives au coût de la collecte et
d'infrastructures d'un tel dispositif
par ailleurs l'article 32 prévoit que le
départ les départements subirait un
report significatif de trafic pour
également étendre ses contributions à
leur réseau les recettes perçues
aurait-elle donc au département ou à la
région on comprend plus rien madame la
ministre
les dépouiller les régions n'ont même
pas la compétence puisque la loi cadets
que je sache n'est n'est pas encore
arrivé au sénat et on donne déjà la
ressource potentielle aux régions pour
pouvoir assumer cette compétence je
crois qu'on a fait peut-être les choses
un petit peu à l'envers
comment s'organisera l'articulation
entre les collectivités en matière de
perception et de gestion des
infrastructures et comment est-il prévu
d'apprécier le caractère significatif de
report plus généralement l'échelle
régionale paraît susceptible de créer
des distorsions importantes entre les
régions induisant une concurrence
fiscale qui pourraient avoir de nombreux
effets pervers en matière de
détournement de trafic
l'instabilité de cette taxe pourrait
également affaiblir l'attractivité de la
france en matière de logistique
alors qu'il s'agit là d'un secteur
stratégique comment comptez vous éviter
ou atténuer ses effets pervers
enfin l'article 36 du projet prévoit
l'interdiction de toute liaison aérienne
vous avez dit que c'était quelque chose
qui vous tenait particulièrement à coeur
pour laquelle plusieurs liaisons
quotidiennes sont disponibles sur le
réseau ferroviaire en moins de 2h30 des
dérogations sont cependant prévus pour
les lignes
avec un haut taux de correspondance
certains acteurs estiment que ce
dispositif pourrait générer non pas
moins d'émissions de co2 mais plus de
détournements de trafic et des
contournements des installations et
compagnie française
pouvez vous nous donner des estimations
chiffrées sur ce point en août la
fermeture de ces lignes entraînera des
conséquences importantes pour les
territoires concernés impactant les
compagnies aériennes mais également
l'attractivité des villes touchées leurs
habitants des mesures d'accompagnement
sont elles prévues afin de limiter ces
impacts madame la ministre
dans la situation économique dans
laquelle se trouve notre pays
je m'inquiète de ce titre se déplace et
qui est principalement fait de taxation
et d'interdiction qui sont l'essence
même de l'écologie punitive que nous ne
voulons pas au sénat et punitifs
particulièrement pour les plus modestes
et qui a déjà été source de trouble dans
notre pays de la même couleur que la
chemise que j'ai ressorti et avec des
gilets jaunes
merci monsieur le rapporteur
je vais maintenant de la parole à ronan
dantec président du groupe de travail
qui va merci monsieur le président une
seule question et qui viendra en écho à
l'introduction du président longeau
puisque le groupe de suivi des relations
des négociations internationales
environnementale justement auditionné
aujourd'hui même marc van de quelaines
qui est l'ambassadeur climat l'union
européenne celui ci nous a d'abord bien
confirmer l'objectif européen de -55% or
vous 52.8 si on compte un certain nombre
de compensation on va pas rentrer dans
ce niveau de détails techniques et
surtout il a il a rajouté un élément
qu'on n'a peut-être pas un encore à
l'esprit qui est que dans la
réglementation européenne
derrière l'objectif européen fixé et la
france a soutenu cet objectif il y as
derrière ce qu'on appelle le règlement
sur la répartition de l'effort
qui est ce que chaque pays devra faire
se donner comme objectif pour 2030
et d'après les éléments qu'on a à ce
stade peut penser que l'objectif final
qu'il sera celui de la france par
l'accord européen sera on va dire entre
mois 42 et -50%
je laisse une marge relativement forte
le problème que nous avons c'est que
d'après les expertises du haut conseil
pour le climat mis en place par le
président de la république et le
gouvernement pour justement expertise et
la loi climat et le président aulas dit
aujourd'hui nous amène plutôt vers un
moins 30 % c'est-à-dire 20% de réduction
d'émissions qui ont déjà eu lieu depuis
1990 est à peu près 10% est encore dans
un dans une perspective où les pensées
se 6 véritablement de ce qu'il ya dans
la loi ou beaucoup de choses sont quand
même que tout incitatives et volontaire
on gagne à peu près 10%
nous on est à moins 30 donc nous aurions
un un objectif européen fixé à la france
entre 42 et 50 et une loi climat qui dit
moins 30
c'est quand même extrêmement
problématique c'est d'autant plus
problématique que dans dans cette
audition très intéressante le
ambassadeur climat l'union européenne
nous a donné un autre chiffre qui est un
chiffre que moi je considère comme
plutôt optimiste qui est qu'avec les
nouveaux engagements pris par l'union
européenne par les états unis où il ya
une véritable dynamique aujourd'hui mais
aussi par le parent par le japon et
d'autres pays
la trajectoire un mondial pour la fin du
siècle arrive maintenant à 2,5 degrés
d'augmentation c'est encore trop mais
c'est moins qu'avant les nouveaux
engagements en perspective de glasgow et
là on est tout à fait dans le mécanisme
prévu par l'accord de paris qui avec le
site de rehaussement l'ambition tous les
cinq ans se donne comme objectif que de
rehaussement heureusement on aille vers
les 2 degrés est donc 2,5 s'est pas
encore suffisant cela sous-entend aussi
que les engagements pris
vaud est retenu mais on voit bien que le
mes
kahnisme de l'accord de paris en fait
fonctionne et dans quand on parle climat
on est souvent défaitiste voir fataliste
là on voit quand même que le mécanisme
fonctionne sauf que si le pays qui a
mobilisé toute sa diplomatie pour
obtenir cet accord de paris et ce
mécanisme heureusement permanent fait
moins 30 % c'est-à-dire au moins un
tiers deux mois que l'objectif que
l'union européenne lui donne dans le
cadre d'un accord que la france a elle
même soutenue
il y a quand même une difficulté de
lisibilité et ma question madame mist la
première c'est à dire mais comment vous
allez expliquer à glasgow que la france
ne fait que moi 30 surtout que nous
savons depuis quelques heures ou
quelques jours que l'allemagne
suite à la censure par la cour
constitutionnelle allemande de sa propre
loi climat est en train de vouloir
afficher c'est ce qu'a dit angela merkel
mois 65 % c'est-à-dire deux fois plus
donc là on a une incohérence sur lequel
il est important de vous entendre qui
fragilise la position de la france dans
les négociations internationales
et vu que cet objectif européen
d'efforts partagés nous le connaîtrons
probablement pas ça c'est peut-être pas
c'est certain mais nous nous le dire est
dans le courant du mois de mai peut-être
donnez-vous mandat d'ailleurs au sénat
de ré atteindre l'objectif européen avec
des amendements plus plus ambitieux en
tout cas je pense que cette
contradiction là doit être levé et que
nous avons besoin de vous entendre sur
ce point merci je vous laisse répondre à
cette série de questions des rapporteurs
et du président du groupe de travail
climat merci beaucoup monsieur le
président déjà beaucoup de questions sur
lesquelles je vais essayer de répondre
de manière la plus synthétique possible
mais je ne voudrais pas non plus vous
laisser sur votre faim donc pour pour
commencer sur sur le stop pub et le whip
hubin l'article 9 madame de sidrac là on
est sur un objectif d'expérimenter pour
les communes
volet collectivités locales volontaires
un dispositif
oui pub afin justement et c'est le
principe dans documenté d'impact en tant
en terme environnemental qu'en termes
social puisqu'on sait qu' il peut y
avoir des des risques sur l'emploi et
mais aussi d'un point de vue économique
sur l'activité industrielle sur la
consommation et c'est juste je vous
remets en tête à queue pour 2019 en est
sûre 894 milton d'imprimés publicitaires
sans adresse qui ont été distribués ça
fait à peu près 30 kg par foyer et par
an et qui sont souvent jetés sans avoir
été lui on est sur 736 mille tonnes de
co2 donc on est vraiment sur un objectif
de lutte contre le gaspillage alors vous
demandez comment ça se coordonnent avec
avec cette affaire de stop pub
l'idée là c'est de faire une
expérimentation qui sera
territorialisées donc on a et on a mis
d'ailleurs dans la loire des limites
pour justement éviter en raisonnement
par l'absurde que toutes les
collectivités se disent oui est chouette
on va essayer louis pub et du coup que
ce soit plus une expérimentation
puisqu'on et les conséquences sans avoir
pu regarder à une échelle plus petite
donc on a mis des limites dans la loi et
donc le fait qu'on fasse à devenir très
territorialisée en mettant des limites
nous permettra de voir justement quels
sont les effets de ce oui pub
est-ce que c'est plus intéressant moins
intéressant que le stop pub est ce que
ça fonctionne quelles sont les
conséquences
et ça nous permettra par la suite de
décider de ce qu'on fait donc il n'y a
pas de contradiction il ya juste que sur
cette question de louis pub
il y avait déjà eu des débats pendant la
loi hajek et vous en souvenez il avait
été décidé d'attendre un peu
là il ya eu une volonté de dire bon on a
besoin de voir comment fonctionnent ces
deux dispositifs pour voir qu'elle est
tout simplement le plus efficace et
d'ailleurs ça correspond plutôt à une
demande un puisque on a une enquête de
l'ademe qui indique que 70% des
répondants se déclarent très ou plutôt
ouverts à ce qu'un système inverse au
stop pub soit testé et appliqués dans
leur commune donc voyons voir ce que
nous pourrons faire
là dessus sur la question de la consigne
sur sur la question de la consigne alors
oui on est dans le prolongement de la
loi hajek
on est en prolongement la loi j'ai qui
met en fait ce qu'on ce qu'on dit tout
simplement si je veux le faire en très
résumé c'est que ce qui est prévu dans
la loi j'ai que ça s'applique aussi pour
le vert c'est de manière extrêmement
simple et donc ça s'applique pour le
vert on a eu beaucoup de débats pendant
l'examen à l'assemblée nationale pour
vérifier ce que ça touche est ce que ça
ne touchait pas on a eu des alertes
concernant par exemple les flacons de
parfum ou concernant les les bouteilles
d'alcool et de spiritueux puisque on
sait que ces bouteilles d'alcool et de
spiritueux pour certaines sont destinés
à l'exportation et donc faire un régime
de consignes quand on a 95 % de ces
bouteilles qui partent à l'étranger
tout ça n'a strictement aucun sens donc
pareil je moi je vous le dis depuis le
début cette fois c'est une loi de bon
sens donc bien évidemment quelque chose
qui va à l'encontre du bon sens on ne
fera pas et donc on va faire en sorte de
regarder pour tous les usages possibles
de la consigne pour lesquelles ça a du
sens et pour lesquels ça n'en a pas et
notamment aussi à travers des distances
qui sont
les distances de d'achalandage et c'est
donc ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui soit qu'ils soient
opérationnels et qui permettent
d'avancer donc on va faire une analyse
en fait de jeu pas si on peut dire une
analyse de cycle de vie mais on va faire
une analyse sur le cycle de la consigne
si l'analyse sur le cycle de la consigne
nous permet de dire que c'est bénéfique
pour l'environnement bien là on le fera
si on voit que en fait ça n'a pas
d'intérêt
on ne le fera pas tout simplement donc
on aura l'occasion d'en rediscuter d'en
rediscuter pendant pendant l'examen du
texte mais voilà voilà le principe qui
me semblait important de vous de vous
rappeler sur la question de l'affichage
environnemental vous avez vous avez
insisté a raison sur la question des
délais en disant que si on veut que les
choses avancent vite pourquoi mettre
cinq ans pour pour mettre en place cet
affichage environnemental
alors faut bien avoir en tête que cette
ce délai de 5 ans est un délai maximum
l'idée est bien de pouvoir commencer
dans certains secteurs qui sont déjà
prêts comme vous l'avait dit il ya des
expérimentations qui ont déjà été
commencée il ya un certain temps je
pense par exemple au secteur de
l'aliment où nous avons un certain
nombre d'entreprises menacées pionnière
qui ont déjà d'ailleurs commencé à
tester un affichage environnemental je
pense à décathlon par exemple qui d'ores
et déjà un affichage environnemental sur
ces produits dont on voit d'ailleurs moi
je suis allé à leur rencontre sur le
terrain qui mérite encore certainement
d'être un peu affiné l'idée là c'est que
on arrive à ce que toutes ces
expérimentations convergent vers un
système qui soit harmonisée et que le
consommateur ne se perdent pas au milieu
des différents des différentes affichage
et qui a un affichage clair et qui soit
compréhensible par tout le monde donc
d'ores et déjà nous avons donc des
expérimentations qui vont se terminer
dans l'année nous avons des
expérimentations donc sur le secteur
d'habillement sur secteur de
l'alimentation qui vont se terminer dans
l'année et donc à partir du moment où
on est prêt eh ben on peut on peut les
lancers et on n'attendra pas évidemment
2025 et nous avons eu des débats je
pense qu'on en aura aussi avec vous sur
le fait que sur l'alimentation il
fallait faire attention à prendre en
compte
plus largement les effets que les effets
carbone puisque nous avons par exemple
des produits de notre alimentation notre
de nos produits agricoles qui sont des
produits de qualité qui sont les
produits labellisés et qui peuvent
émettre un peu plus de gaz à effet de
serre mais qui par contre en terme
d'impact global sur l'environnement sont
bien meilleurs et nous avons adopté un
certain nombre d'amendements en première
lecture donc à l'assemblée pour
justement mettre en place ces critères
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de des fêtes de
bordes effets pervers qui en fait y
aurait un peu à l'encontre de ce que de
ce que nous souhaitons faire puisque
nous sommes nous ne sommes pas un
carbone score c'est pour ça que je
disais tout à l'heure nous ne sommes pas
dans le carbone score de la convention
citoyenne nous sommes sur une étiquette
environnementale
donc il est plus large que le score
carbone même si le l'aspect carbone
serait indiquée mais il ne sera pas il
sera ce sera plus large sur eux
sur la question du vrac
donc on est sur un article qui prévoit
donc au 1er janvier 2030 les commères
les commerces de vente au détail dans la
surface est supérieure ou égale à 400
mètres carrés donc on n'est pas sur les
petits consacrent au moins 20% leur
surface de vente de produits de grande
consommation ou un dispositif d'effet
équivalent en exprimant en nombre de
références ou en proportion du chiffre
d'affaires à la vente de produits
présentés sans emballages primaires y
compris la vente en vrac on dira par
décret quels sont les précisions sur les
objectifs à atteindre sur les catégories
de produits et c'est ce qu'on a modifié
à l'assemblée
c'était on a fait des modifications pour
mieux cibler les produits pour lesquels
il existe un enjeu et un potentiel de
développement de la vente sans emballage
on a limité le texte aux produits de
grande consommation qui sont définies
par décret sur l'article 441 tiré 4 du
code de commerce par exemple les
articles de bricolage les meubles et
livres les vêtements ne seront pas
concernés évidemment mais les produits
alimentaires et d'entretien oui on a
élargi et produits intégrés dans
l'objectif de 20% pour inclure des
produits vendu à la découpe assisté en
magasin les produits vendus sans
emballage mais en quantité non choisi
par le consommateur qui ne sont donc pas
un plus dans la définition législatives
vivra du vrac on a donné de la souplesse
aussi dans la manière de calculer
l'atteinte de l'objectif de 20 % en 2030
en part de surface de vente
il va y avoir des système d'équivalence
par exemple ou départ des produits
référencés par le commerce soit un
pourcentage du chiffre d'affaires et on
prévoit vraiment une adaptation par voie
réglementaire pour tenir compte des
spécificités des filières on à cette
question du polystyrène qui a été qui a
été rajouté donc ça a été un vote qui a
été fait contre l'avis du gouvernement
en ce on est en réflexion sur le sujet
depuis que ceux de pics et à cet article
cet amendement a été adopté la loi anti
gaspillage
elle prévoit de toute façon de tendre
vers l'objectif de 100% plastiques
recyclés d'ici 1er janvier 2025
ce qui suppose en premier lieu que les
résines employés soient recyclables par
définition et dispose d'une filière de
recyclage opérationnel le polystyrène à
ce jour ne dispose pas de filière de
recyclage opérationnel en france mais il
est recyclé par exemple en espagne pour
fabriquer des cintres et des équipements
de bureautique
alors il faut quand même noter que
plusieurs projets de recyclage simic ont
été récemment annoncées en france où
sont à l'état pilote technologique et la
loi gaspillage et la directive
européenne sur les plastiques à usage
unique elle prévoit déjà un par ailleurs
l'interdiction différents produits en
plastique à usage unique dont certains
composés de polystyrène expansé mais ne
prévoit pas une interdiction générale
sur tous les produits
les emballages constitué de polystyrène
donc eu une interdiction par principe
d'un type de matériaux au niveau
national ne me paraissent pas une bonne
solution car ce serait contraire aux
directives européennes et c'est pourquoi
nous avons émis un avis défavorable
pendant l'examen à l'assemblée en fait
seuls les emballages qui ne sont non
valorisables peuvent être interdits et
ce qui n'est pas le cas du polystyrène
puisqu'il est déjà donc recyclé en
certains pays européens donc en revanche
la france j'y vais doucement parce que
je pense que la réflexion n'est pas
terminée là dessus c'est pour ça que je
fais attention à ce que je vous dis puis
on aura l'occasion d'en discuter mais la
france a joué un rôle moteur pour
inscrire en droit européen la
possibilité de mettre en place des
incitations économiques à
l'éco-conception des emballages et ses
incitations elles prennent la forme de
bonus malus qui sont fixés dans le cadre
des filières rep et le principe il avait
été inscrit dans la loi à gec est
d'ailleurs la loi prévoit qu'un arrêté
fixe pour 2022 une pénalité applicables
aux emballages plastiques ne peuvent pas
intégrer une filière de recyclage et
donc on peut s'appuyer sur ses
dispositions pour favoriser des
emballages éco-conçus on a aussi un
problème de toxicité par contre pour
l'homme qui est
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'on a eu ce
débat aussi dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée
ce n'est pas le polystyrène qui
présentent un risque de toxicité mais en
fait le monomère de ce polymère qui est
classé reprotoxique au niveau européen
et donc c'est plutôt au moment de la
production du polymère et non au moment
de l'utilisation qu'il est qu'il est
dangereux et donc il faudra prendre des
précautions
voilà ce que je peux vous dire pour
l'instant on a des entreprises qui
proposent des solutions alternatives
vertueuse
on a vraiment une mobilisation avec le
pacte national sur les emballages
plastiques qui traite aussi de cette
question maintenant j'entends j'entends
le message qu'ont voulu nous faire
passer les députés donc c'est une
discussion qui à mon avis devra
continuer et je suis certaine que vos
apports mesdames et messieurs sénatrices
et sénateurs seront seront précieux sur
les courts pour finir si j'ai pas
répondu à tous je vous répondrais sûr
évidemment d'autres questions sur la
question de la mise en danger de
l'environnement les débats seront
nombreux sur le sujet je n'ai pas de
doute il faut bien comprendre que si on
est si sévère c'est parce que là la
question de la mise en danger de
l'environnement arrivera après un
processus terre c'est pas juste
quelqu'un qui fait une entreprise qui
met en danger l'environnement qui se
fait taper sur les doigts et qui se
prend tout de suite une amende très
forte
là on parle notamment dit cpe où il y
aurait déjà eu des processus de mise en
demeure préalable
donc on sera sur des entreprises qui
sciemment auront reçu des mises en
demeure
or ont été alertés n'auront rien fait et
là seront dans la situation d'être
sanctionné très fortement et la deuxième
situation ce qui est qui est un peu
représentatif de ces cas ce seront des
entreprises qui est qui travaillent ce
qui est travail sans autorisation c'est
à dire qu'ils n'ont pas l'autorisation
de de fonctionner et qui fonctionne donc
on n'est pas du tout sûr quelqu'un qui
ferait une erreur une fois
on n'est pas du tout sûr sûr sûr ce
niveau là voilà ce que je pouvais vous
dire madame de staël vous allez poser
beaucoup de questions
pascal martin sur la question de la
cambre delà de la commande publique
merci d'abord de souligner les avancées
notamment sur les contrats de concession
oui bien sûr l'état déjà d'ores et déjà
prévu de mettre à disposition des
collectivités territoriales un certain
nombre d'outils et des guides pour les
aider dans leur dans leurs commandes
dans leurs commandes publiques bien sûr
sur l'article 19 bis sur les moulins
alors nous avons une très très longue
discussion sur ce sujet et nous en
aurons certainement une dent dans
l'hémicycle du sénat et c'est tant mieux
parce que on est sur un sujet qui génère
beaucoup d'émotion je crois qu'il faut
qu'on sorte de l'émotion et qu'on
revienne sur des faits d'abord il faudra
qu'on regarde je pense que ce serait
intéressant qu'on puisse avoir des
chiffres dont on pourra discuter dans
l'hémicycle du sénat il faudra qu'on a
dit qu'on est des chiffres pour regarder
combien
concrètement réellement de moulins je
parle bien des moulins ont été détruits
pour des opérations de continuité
écologique des cours d'eau
il y en a peut-être s'il y en a c'est
extrêmement peu et je crois que
légiférer de manière aussi lourde sur
des situations qui sont aussi peu
nombreuses
ça me paraît un petit peu effectivement
excessif
après il y à un certain nombre de
problèmes sur certains territoires et il
faut bien sûr y remédier et nous nous
pouvons trouver des solutions là le
texte qui a été voté et très
déséquilibré dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui un propriétaire qui
voudraient lui même faire un effacement
de seuil c'est à dire que là on ne
touche pas la strong touche pas aux
bâtiments du moulin là on touche aux
seuls qui sont dans l'eau et qui empêche
effectivement la continuité là dans le
texte tel qu'il est aujourd'hui un effet
un propriétaire qui voudraient le faire
n'aurait plus le droit de le faire donc
on arrive dans quelque chose qui est
excessif de la même manière
en y regardant de plus près nous nous
rendons compte que ce qui a été voté est
en fait un recul de 1 recul en termes de
droit de la protection de
l'environnement ce qui est quand même un
petit peu embêtant moi j'avais dit que
je ne voulais pas quitter d'orchestra
protection de l'environnement donc
revenir à une rédaction qui sait qu'ils
seraient plus équilibrée qui permettrait
de prendre en compte les légitimes
aspirations à ce qu'on garde notre
patrimoine et je crois qu'ici on est
tous d'accord sur la valeur de notre
patrimoine et la nécessité de garder
mais tout en préservant j'insiste sur
l'importance de préserver la continuité
écologique des cours d'eau
on ne se rend pas compte de ce que
malheureusement de ce que peut apporter
une biodiversité préservée dans les
cours d'eau de même il ya une question
de privilégier le petit hydro
hydroélectrique le petit hydroélectrique
peut apporter des solutions dans un
certain nombre de situations ça peut
être intéressant maintenant en termes
d'apport de cette pas de
l'hydroélectrique au sein du mix
électrique français il est assez faible
et donc avoir un tel impact sur la
biodiversité des cours d'eau pour un
effet aussi faible sur notre mix
électrique faut qu'on fasse attention à
la proportionnalité des mesures que nous
votons donc retravaillions ensemble pour
trouver une rédaction qui soigne une
rédaction
plus pragmatique et en même temps qu'ils
tiennent compte des aspirations et des
uns et des autres je suis tout à fait
disposé pour pour y travailler avec vous
sur
alors
sur sur la question de
l'eau potable faut pas oublier aussi que
là on arrive après un processus qui a
été le processus des assises de l'eau
qui a fait travailler le nombre d'entre
vous et nombre d'entre nous nous avons
beaucoup travaillé sur le petit site de
l'eau sur les gaspillages que vous avez
rappelé qu'ils sont importants
nous avons engagé des fonds du plan de
relance aussi pour aider les
collectivités à travailler là dessus
notamment aussi pour les collectivités
d'outre-mer qu'on oublie trop souvent
mais qui sont qui sont très touchés par
parce par ces problèmes d'eau et
ce que je vous propose là dessus si je
n'ai pas d'autres chiffres c'est qu'on
puisse en reparler parce que n'est pas
tout les derniers les derniers chiffres
que je pourrais vous apporter mais on en
rediscutera en séance sur la stratégie
nationale des aires protégées
alors vous insistez monsieur le sénateur
sur un point très important qui est la
question des moyens humains
je partage évidemment cet objectif si on
veut avoir des aires protégées il faut
qu'on ait des gens dessus moi on ne me
fera pas jamais croire qu'on peut
protéger un espace d'autant plus quand
il est grand uniquement à partir d'un
bureau parisien
voilà quelque chose qui qui est une
évidence parfois il faut le rappeler
c'est pourquoi je suis heureuse d'avoir
déjà obtenu suite aux annonces qui ont
été faites par le président de la
république une augmentation de 40 40 tp
sur l'eau au fbi et pour les parcs
nationaux
l'eau avait évidemment pour la question
des aires marines protégées et cette
augmentation doit être suivi d'autres
normalement
l'année prochaine je sais que cette
augmentation ne permet pas de tout
résoudre mais vous comprendrez bien que
c'est un point qui est important pour
moi et sur lequel nous allons travailler
notamment dans l'optique du prochain
projet de loi de finances sur les aires
protégées en elle-même à ce stade nous
sommes environ à 24 % d'aires protégées
il reste donc du chemin à parcourir
la cible évidemment elle est atteignable
il faut évidemment qu'on identifie et là
c'est le rôle de tout de tout le monde
les zones qui méritent d'être protégés
de concrétiser leur classement
il ya un certain nombre de sites connus
qui mériterait d'être protégé et on est
en cours de travail pour lancer ou
finaliser des classements mais également
pour rendre plus solides leur modèle
financier parce qu'il ya pas que les
moyens humains il ya aussi les modèles
financiers et leur suivi
pour ce qui est de la protection forte
les choses sont identiques même s'il
s'agit de ce site encore plus
exceptionnel évidemment la marche est un
peu plus difficile à franchir vous
l'avait dit pour atteindre notre
objectif puisque nous en sommes
virons à 2% mais je crois que nous
pouvons y arriver avec l'implication de
toutes et tous mais encore une fois là
c'est vraiment du travail de dentelle
sur sur des territoires sur sur la
question du code minier avec les
implications que vous vous disiez sur le
bilan carbone alors j'ai pas répondu
tout à l'heure sur les questions de
l'étude d'impact il va pas y avoir des
études d'impact qui va être fait avant
le passage pour le sénat parce qu'on
n'est pas dans la capacité de faire
aussi rapidement maintenant bien
évidemment les choses ont bougé puisque
il y a eu un certain nombre d'éléments
qui ont été rajoutés dans cette loi qui
vont avoir un impact très positif je
l'espère notamment sur ce qui a été fait
suite à la mission seashell par exemple
sur le sur le bâtiment mais sur le code
minier
on va y regarder de plus près je vais
essayer de vous apporter des réponses
très précises mais en tout cas en
aujourd'hui pour préserver
l'environnement et donc là c'est pour ça
que je fais la nuance entre co2 et
environnement en général mais pour
préserver l'environnement
nous avons besoin de réformer le code
minier qui naquit n'était absolument pas
adaptée et qui permettait justement par
toujours cet exemple emblématique mais
c'est parce qu'il est facile et qu'il
est bien identifiée sur la montagne
dorment n'avions aucun moyen parce que
le code minier n'avait pas été adapté
depuis longtemps de nous opposer un
projet dont tout le monde voyait qu'il
avait un impact environnemental majeur
mais l époque où le code minier a été
rédigé ces préoccupations n'étaient pas
encore très présente dans nos esprits
sur la portée juridique de l'article 62
sur les engrais azotés
comme vous l'avez vu cette portée
juridique elle est assez faible dans la
mesure et là je parle d'un point de vue
juridique dans la mesure où la taxe
n'est pas mise dans le dur de la loi en
revanche la portée politique et la
portée en termes d' influence sur
l'activité nos agriculteurs est
importante et d'ailleurs je pense que le
débat qui a eu à l'assemblée sur le
sujet en termes de d'intensité montrent
à quel point il a fait réagir parce que
il explique que nous avons une
trajectoire est d'ailleurs une
trajectoire européenne nous nous nous
accompagnons cette trajectoire et nous
disons que nous souhaitons aider les
agriculteurs à atteindre les objectifs
qui sont des objectifs encore une fois
qu'ils sont y compris imposées au niveau
européen et que s'ils le font si si il y
arrive et si ça se passe bien il n'y
aura pas de deux taxes en revanche si on
n'arrive pas à atteindre les objectifs
là on mettra en place une taxe danser
c'est pour donner aussi des perspectives
pour expliquer que dans un premier temps
on ne met pas de taxe parce qu'on n'a
pas envie de d'embêter les agriculteurs
ce conte par contre on est obligé
d'atteindre un certain nombre
d'objectifs donc là c'est plutôt pour
leur dire regardez
en fait pour pour le pour être plus sûrs
d'atteindre nos objectifs on pourrait
mettre une taxe tout de suite mais on a
on a plutôt envie d'être dans une
démarche de travail ensemble et
d'accompagnement donc on vous dit que là
pour l'instant on n'a même pas mais que
si besoin est on admettra il s'avère
qu'on avait déjà utilisé cette technique
sur les gages les gaz hfc et ça avait
bien marché sur les gages sûrs et gaz
hfc on avait dit on va mettre en place
une taxe mais si vous respectez vos
engagements de baisse d'émissions de ses
gaz et bien la taxe sera sera annulée ça
a été le cas donc comme quoi c'est
parfois il faut il suffit de donner des
perspectives
monsieur tabarot sur les à des feux
alors vous parlez des échéances des
échéances qui sont inscrites dans le
texte de loi
il faut bien faire attention parce que
vous avez raison sur de souligner que
nous avons dit que nous voulions que les
collectivités s'empare de cette
possibilité et qu'elle puisse vraiment
forger leurs outils en fonction des
spécificités de leur territoire là ce
qui est mis dans le dur de la loi sur
les interdictions en 2000
23 2024 et 2025 où on arriverait à une
interdiction des vignettes critères 3 en
c'est pour les collectivités qui dépasse
et qui dépasserait à ce moment là encore
les seuils de pollution régulièrement
j'ai pu les j'ai pu le
le niveau 2
deux réguliers mais je pourrais vous
leur donnez donc ça ne concerne pas
toutes les et des feux on est sur les
éditions sur des collectivités
spécifique qui seraient consacrées qui
seraient confrontés à ces problèmes là
pour les autres elles peuvent elles
peuvent adapter encore une fois en
fonction de leurs besoins sur sur la
question des contrôles humains
on travaille avec le ministère de
l'intérieur pour que le plus vite
possible on puisse avoir des contrôles
automatisés en principe des contrôles
automatisés c'est tout simplement c'est
comme les contrôles de vitesse vous avez
un radar qui flashe et l'amande part
directement
on sait bien qu'au niveau des contrôles
humains se sera pas possible d'avoir
suffisamment de personnel pour pouvoir
faire des contrôles aussi efficace que
les contrôles automatisés c'est une
évidence
donc dans un pré ces contrôles humains
seront par vidéo verbalisation variera
une personne qui regardera derrière la
caméra de manière c'est artisanal mais
ce sera avec des personnes l'idée c'est
que ça dure le moins longtemps possible
et on sait que pendant ce temps là on
sera dans les zones d'installer dans des
périodes d'installation de l'aser des
feux ou la volonté c'est aussi de faire
beaucoup de pédagogie en l'idée de la
sanction évidemment qu'il faut des
sanctions mais il faut avant les
sanctions
beaucoup beaucoup de pédagogie faire
comprendre comment ça marche
moi là j'ai vu que j'étais dans la
métropole de lyon récemment ils ont mis
en place une voie de covoiturage la voix
de covoiturage bon bah déjà il faut
comment il faut que les gens comprennent
ce que c'est il faut que tu comprennes
qui a droit ni rentrer etc et donc il
faut se laisser un peu de temps quand
même aux populations pour qu'elles pour
qu'elle comprenne de quoi il s'agit
[Musique]